字幕: Kayoko Shiomi
校正: Yasushi Aoki
（音楽）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
皆さん こんにちは
ハンドパン奏者の
cojicoseと申します
今演奏していたこの楽器は
ハンドパンという楽器になります
一見UFOみたいな
民族楽器のような形をしていますが
楽器の歴史の中で見ると
とても新しく
今から22年前の西暦2001年に
スイスで誕生しました
僕がハンドパンに出会ったのは
今から８年前になります
ある日 友人のハンドパンを
初めて見た時に
一瞬で その音の魅力に
引き込まれました
そして その日の夜には
ハンドパンメーカーに
「試作品のハンドパンでいいので
買いたいです
何とかなりませんか？」と
連絡を取っていました
ハンドパンには
３つ特徴があります
まず その１は この音色
（音色）
何とも言えない このポワーンという
とても綺麗な音です
これには「倍音」という
音が含まれています
また それが綺麗に
調律されているので
一つの場所を叩くだけでも
このように聞こえます
特徴 その２は
音の数が 他の楽器と比べて
とても少ないということです
このへこんでいる部分が
（音色）
ピアノの鍵盤部分に当たります
例えば グランドピアノは
88種類の音階・鍵盤があります
一般的なギターは49音
それに対して
これは両面合わせて19音
もう一つのハンドパンが
15音になります
特徴 その３は
それぞれのハンドパンによって
スケールと言われる音階が異なります
スケールとは簡単に言うと
音楽の雰囲気を作り出すものです
もう一つ 今日 僕は
面白いものを持ってきました
こちらは 「おりん」と言います
家の仏壇にある
チーンと鳴らす「おりん」です
このおりんは とても音に
こだわりをもって製作されたもので
「佐波理おりん」と
呼ばれるものになります
（音色）
この佐波理おりんの音色は
すっきりとした音色で
どこか懐かしく
心地よい余韻を奏でます
ハンドパンの音色とは対照的で
倍音があまり含まれていなく
音叉のように
特定の音のみが揺らがずに鳴ります
（音色）
この佐波理おりんは
京都の宇治にある
南條工房さんというところで
製造されているもので
すべて音楽的に
調律されたものであり
ハンドパンの音と
心地よく調和します
さて これから
皆さんと一緒に
「ただ音を感じる」という時間を
共有できたらと思います
音というのは周波数の波です
その波を ただ感じてみてください
（音色）
ハンドパンの音からは
どんな音が聞こえますか？
ドレミの音は限定的で
少ないですが
叩き方を工夫すれば
いろんな音を 音楽として
奏でることができます
例えば このように
ミュートしたり
音盤の周りを叩いてみたり
指の骨でノックしてみたり
こういうのも
いろんな音が鳴ります
強弱によっても
音の鳴り方が変わります
大きく叩くほど
周りの音盤が共鳴して
豪華でリッチな
サウンドになります
（音色）
おりんの音が
ハンドパンと混ざり合い
綺麗に調和しているのが
感じられるでしょうか？
とてもシンプルな構造で
音の数に制限がある
その中で世界観を
表現するというのが
僕はハンドパンのとても
面白いところだと思っています
それでは皆さん 一度ちょっと
ゆっくり深呼吸をしていただいて
リラックスをしていただいて
しばらく音の波の世界に
耳を傾けてみてください
（音楽）
ありがとうございました
（拍手）